we heard your president speak in a
historic address in the uk house of
commons yesterday
and he received a standing ovation if
you read the front pages of our
newspapers today his words are being
lauded and celebrated but after that
speech does he feel he got the action
from the uk to back up the standing
ovation and all the plaudits
well first of all we are grateful to our
uk allies and friends of course it's
only been a day so it's hard to say but
i think
we're really fighting hard for a no-fly
zone as everyone knows we have to
protect our skies in order to protect
our people
now there is a lot of hesitancy on the
part of the west to do that we
understand this but one way or another
they have to give us the military
facilities to implement on all flies or
at least by ourselves we have to prevent
the russians from being able to bomb our
cities to kill our civilians they're
shooting indiscriminately in our
population and so this has to stop
how vital is
nato members and the west
supplying air support to ukraine because
we hear about the
russian troops advancing on the capital
as we speak we hear about the bombing of
maripol we've just talked about a
children's hospital that's been
completely destroyed today how vital is
air support
air support is extremely vital without
air support
the russian advance on the ground comes
to a hold it's it's virtually impossible
or much harder to implement for them so
air support is incredibly important and
that's what we're fighting for
essentially the russians so far haven't
been able to capture any major cities of
symbolic value of course kiev but
mariupol is in real danger it's a city
in the south in the eastern part if they
will be able to be able to capture that
city god forbid they will have a direct
route to continental the rest of russia
through ukraine and to crimea that will
be a huge symbolic
hugely important symbolic issue for them
and we can't let that happen
what is the president's response to the
fact that nato members say we can't give
you
anything that would be seen as an
offensive weapon everything we give you
has to be defensive because if we do
it is then bringing nato into direct
conflict with russia what is his
response to that
well i think his response has any
response
on the part of the ukrainian people
right now would be to say look there
already is a full-scale war in the
middle of europe there's already
thousands of people dead and dying as we
speak what else needs to happen
for the west to realize that this is a
crisis or a war that's not just going to
go away without something materially
changing that's sooner or later the west
will have to live up to the fact that it
will have to confront
this regime the russian regime it just
doesn't it's not going to disappear by
itself so i would say the sooner the
west
realizes this the better for everyone
and the less costly it is for everyone
can you give me an idea of what life is
like for the president of ukraine at the
moment he has been very vocal saying
that he is not leaving the capital he's
posted videos on social media showing
the effects of the war on the city of
kiev he's given addresses and from his
presidential office talk to me about a
day in the life of vladimir zelinski at
the moment
well of course i can't go into the
details here but um everyone is in
ukraine uh of course you know we're
standing up to the fight we're gonna
stand our ground and defend our country
defend our cities so there's no question
about that um but of course it's it's
not easy it's a serious you know
challenge it's a crisis of our life over
a lifetime it's a full-scale war so of
course it's not easy
yeah i understand that you do have to be
careful and of course the president does
have his security team around him but we
do hear uh about him being targeted
several times already how secure is he
so we believe
and we have grounds to be confident that
he's very secure
i mean there have been attempts as
everyone knows by now on his life we
have been able to
defeat those attempts if you want to
basically disarm all these groups and
liquidate them so i don't think there is
a serious chance of them having any
success
but the situation speaks for itself i
mean
there are these things happening there
is a war and there's obviously
constantly an attempt on his life uh mr
rodianski we just have
heard from your president on social
media i just want to read viewers what
he had to say within the last few
moments he's tweeted this uh it's about
that bombing we were talking about in
maripol targeting a hospital he said
there's been a direct strike of russian
troops at the maternity hospital people
children are under the wreckage an
atrocity how much longer will the world
be an accomplice ignoring terror close
the sky right now these are the words of
the ukrainian president he goes on to
say stop the killings you have power but
you seem to be losing humanity
that gives us an idea um
doesn't it of just how desperate the
situation is and
for all the western leaders applauding
vladimir celenski's bravery and his
strong words about his country
again it doesn't sound like he feels
like he's getting enough
that's right and that's what i've been
saying just now in this conversation
all of ukraine believes that we're not
getting enough i mean what else needs to
happen
for the west to realize that this is a
conflict that they will be engaged in
more directly anyway you will have to
you know confront this regime one way or
another and the sooner the west realizes
this the better the less costly it's
going to be the less lives will be lost
and of course we're looking at our on
the destruction in our country at the
lives being lost in our country
and we're wondering why is everybody
just sitting back
yeah
sitting back is
a good way of putting it in terms of
people are saying the west are helping
in terms of
humanitarian aid military support where
it can in terms of being defensive
but do you feel that
nato in the west has been a step behind
here and now is the time to look further
ahead because
if ukraine falls
what next is it the baltics nato member
states
that's exactly right so concretely we
need
full scale most advanced air defense
systems so we need high to medium air
defense systems we need some way to
shoot down their cruise missiles their
medium range ballistic missiles
those are giving us a hard time as you
can see i mean they're killing innocent
civilians bombing indiscriminately or
maybe on purpose as we know that's their
war methods sometimes um so we have to
we have to do something against that and
you are right there seems to be a step
behind when it comes to nato or western
partners to give us that military
capability
diplomatic efforts are still continuing
every day here on sky news we talk about
different western leaders meeting in
different western countries holding news
conferences we have the foreign
secretary of the uk meeting her u.s
counterpart later we'll be hearing from
them these diplomatic efforts continue
and the west still seems to have faith
in those kind of efforts in turning the
tide in this war and bringing a halt
to president putin's action do you have
any faith in diplomacy at this point
so this is what i've also been saying
repeatedly i think
these
assumptions are a bit naive at this
point we the russian regime has really
revealed its true nature before this
escalation before this war had started
there are doubts about the true nature
of the russian regime you could have
some disagreement about whether you
should arm ukraine or not because if you
armed ukraine maybe you would have
escalated the crisis but now after the
fact when we saw the real nature the
real face of this regime we can
understand that it's not going to go
away by itself
it's not really interested in dialogue
it's been exploiting the transparency
and the honesty of the west throughout
the whole process it's been lying across
across all these years at every single
step we heard this in crimea there was
no russian troops in crimea and then the
next day there were russian groups in
crimea just before this war started we
also heard that there was just a
military exercise and then 20th of
february all the troops were going to
return home they never returned home and
then you had a real invasion
so you how can you trust this side how
can you really seek dialogue at this
stage you're not dealing with a regular
democratic country that you can rely on
in terms of the promises that it's
making here you evidently cannot rely on
what they're saying so the approach has
changed
the approach does seem to be from the
west um targeted at sanctions at
squeezing russia's economy we've been
hearing about uh banning russian oil
we've been talking about and then being
taken out of key banking systems and big
companies pulling out of russia and
really hitting their economy
that takes a while to take effect
does ukraine have that time
well that's the that's the battle we're
fighting essentially on the one hand we
need full military support and our
military has done wonders already nobody
expected us to hold up like this for two
weeks
with basically the russian side being
under pressure and not being able to
have any strategic success so far so
that's number one we need full military
support and we've spoken about that just
now the second part is to make sure that
economically russia comes under serious
pressure such that it cannot finance
this war anymore unfortunately i mean i
hate to say this that there's nothing in
the long run we want peace and stability
with our with russia right i mean
they're not going to go away but at this
moment we have to put maximum pressure
on them economically such that they do
not have the resources eventually to
continue killing our people and to
waging them to wage this war so that
means
tough sanctions tough economic general
sanctions not just targeting the
individual sanctions and the the quicker
the better
and can we just have a final question
about what your president has described
as the
humanitarian catastrophe that is facing
ukraine right now and
so much has been pledged by
the west in terms of humanitarian aid
now we're looking at the difficulties of
refugees leaving ukraine these
humanitarian corridors and ceasefires
being breached regularly
how easy is it for all this humanitarian
aid to get to where it needs to cities
like kiev to maripole that are
surrounded by russian troops we hear
about people being just days away from
completely running out of food and water
well you're addressing an issue that's
just been
completely impossible for me and for me
personally and for all of us here to
comprehend i mean the russian side seems
to be sabotaging
all these corridors all the humanitarian
aid i mean we've seen this as part of
their methods in other conflicts in
syria for example but we don't have a
clear understanding of why they're doing
it i mean they're bombing our cities
probably with some perfidious objective
in mind to just scare the population
into submitting or whatever but we have
we have no understanding why they're
killing civilians fleeing through these
corridors for example there's been
english indiscriminate shooting at
civilians with their luggage and
children just being killed on the spot
and there is no explanation for that i
mean we can't fathom what the
explanation is except that this war that
the russian regime has been waging has
unleashed all of its viciousness all of
the viciousness that's been building up
in that society in that army over the
years and now it's being unleashed upon
us i mean it's just as tragic as it can
get and i don't really have a response
to it